phục nâm sĩ gần nghiên ăn mười hai nân cộng bản đến chường.
Cô chuyện nâm sĩ gần nghiên ăn, xuất mề hai nâm luôn đầu hành xúc đỡ,
cộng bản đến chường chia sẻ trên trang cộng đồng nghiên ăn,
nhé được nhiều lời khát gọi từ cộng đồng mạng.
Đó là em vi tấn khăn ở bản định tiến sẽ cho hạnh hệ khí châu nghiên ăn.
Họng sĩ nhất sẽ là, cảm nằm sáo chừng giữ họ phủ tông khí châu.
xuất mề hai nâm qua, châu dù nặng hai mơ gió,
tuần khăn luôn luôn đầu hành xúc đỡ,
tổng người bạn của mình là vi nhật cảnh đến chường.
Ví tấn khăn xích ra chungu dạ định đồng bảo dưới tổn khái nhau ở sả trâu hành.
Mặc dù vậy, khách vận nãy bản thân người bạn cộng bạn là vi nhật cảnh,
thân bệnh bạn nào khiến xuất tay trên cộng bình có quốc,
đi lại hết sức có khăn ngay từ khi cơ nhau.
Trương bạn, nhiều nâm này, tuần khăn chữ thành đưa trên cộng cảnh,
nay ngay đưa bạn để chường.
Không chỉ hẳng ngày xúc đỡ bạn đến chường,
tấn khăn còn giúp đỡ bạn trong học tập,
năm lúc mười lấp mềm hộn,
khách cả thọc lực khác, năm lập mề hài lọc sinh rồi.
Chí sẽ bị cộ học cho của mình,
cô hoa, giá viên chữ nghiệp của tấn khăn cho biết,
tấn khăn là một thọc sinh chăm 1, học rồi.
Lên hoa đồng, xuất đợi bản mẹ,
lần hành thả nghiệp vụ được sao,
sẽ đi ngủ khăn khó khăn,
nhưng em luôn cô khăn trong học tập và công việc.
Tấn khăn là một tấn gức sáng để các bạn trẻ học tập ở nơi theo,
tấn khăn và dịch cạnh là đời bản cuộc tiến,
su cã hai đều có h案 cạnh khó khăn,
nhưng các tâm luôn đồng hành,
xuất đợi lệ nhau cho học tập,
biết vượt lên trong cuộc sống.